[Music]
Completed, Empire B.
Sword Empire B using materials from
Queen.  I'm glad that that's
not the case. I was
wondering what to do when I couldn't use my main weapon. I
needed to manage not only Bash and Emil's favorability, but the other rabbits as well.  I
thought to myself, ``Why don't you play gal games?'' I thought, ``I have to supervise the rabbits that are going to appear in the future.'' What
happened to these
12 girls whose brains were trembling from the trauma of playing gal games?  There are times when I have to adjust the high sensitivity of the heroine to make sure there's not even a 1 second difference, and just by
letting my guard down for a moment, my likability is as good as winning dominoes.For some reason, all of the heroines
go to Italy for pizza training and are bad.  It's the
end.
What are you trying to tell me? Pickled tuna, mountain
village youth lost to pizza.